all right oh yeah Illya thank you very
much Betty Illya thank you john grisham
is considered the king of the legal
thriller the best-selling author has
sold more than 300 million copies of his
books worldwide and they include
classics like the firm a time to kill
and the Pelican brief his newest novel
is called the guardians it tells the
story of a murdered lawyer and one of
the organization's journey and one
organization's journey to exonerate a
man wrongfully convicted and imprisoned
for 22 years the Los Angeles Times
called it an inside look at the dirty
machineries of process and power with
plenty of entertainment we would not
expect him to lose that John Grisham
joins us at the table thank you for
being here
always a pleasure welcome 300 million
plus books but who's counting I mean I
love it where they just round up to 300
million yeah keep rounding it was 300
last year
I know but John are you doing a book a
year it seems I said wasn't John just
here are you doing a book E or I marvel
that you can do this I've done a book a
year since 1991 Wow Wow and everyone has
gone to number one yes
well yes but who's counting so with the
new one Colin Post is the lawyer turned
minister I was not aware that lawyers
could become ministers least not lawyers
in your book typically before he's a
reformed lawyer he's a lawyer in
recovery who founds God and that's what
with that yeah it's his calling to take
innocence cases and exonerate innocent
people from prison and it's based on
some real-life innocence lawyers on
though who dedicate their careers to
exonerating innocent people because
there are a lot of innocent people in
prison yeah he tries to help a character
named quincy miller who's a black man
convicted of murder maintaining his
innocence yes he becomes convinced that
quincy is innocent he takes the case and
he gets more than he bargained for
because the the the real murderer in
Quincy's case does not want quincy out
of prison right and so the end the real
murderer is still out there so it gets
really complicated they're still trying
to get quincy and you also tell about
Duke Russell who was also on death row
and and so but was this inspired by your
own work with the Innocence Project you
started looking at these cases and said
there is a story here cuz you're right
there are a lot of stories like
gaile every innocence case every
wrongful conviction is a fantastic story
yeah because of the level of human
suffering the injustice the just
storytelling all the all the factors
that we love in stories they're there in
a wrongful conviction again I wish I
could write every one of them publish
the innocent man Maui nonfiction book in
2006 and I became aware of wrongful
convictions and how many of them there
are and and we see them all the time to
all these generations and they're just
fantastic stories and again I wish I had
time to write all of you dedicate this
to James McCluskey the exonerate er has
that he's a remarkable man he started an
outfit called Centurion ministries 45
years ago and for 45 years James has
kind of roam the country taking a few
cases at a time and if 45 years later he
has exonerated 63 people well innocent
people that's his that's his claim to
fame dedicate his life to it and
Centurion ministries now is based in
Princeton is a wonderful organization
with a with a staff and they litigate
from coast to coast and get innocent
people out the other thing that the book
touches on is how you get these experts
forensic experts to testify and often
the what they're testifying is very
faulty evidence and they know that it's
junk science junk junk sciences how you
describe it seems to happen a lot oh it
happens every day yeah we have no
forensic standards in this country we're
trying we're trying to adopt them but
there are thousands of people in prison
who were put there by bogus experts
people who testify about bite mark
analysis or boot print analysis or blood
prints blood most of us most of it's not
based on science and what's happened
that DNA's come along now and expose
some of these guys but it's still
impossible to get the innocent people
out of prison and we're working with the
Innocence Project Centurion ministries
the innocence community is working to
undo so many bogus convictions based on
junk science why why doesn't there are
so many people getting out of prison
proving to be innocent yes that it would
shake my faith in the legal process if I
were a lawyer or a judge you used to be
a lawyer I mean you ever hear of a
prosecutor saying I can't be in this
business anymore because I have doubt
now I don't hear that what you what you
see though jurors
are far more skeptical now they don't
believe everything that the police and
prosecutors tell them that's why death
verdicts are declining rapidly in
America oh wow that's why the death
penalty is dying
not because of courageous lawmakers not
because of courageous judges but because
of courageous jurors who hear the whole
story and they and some of these crimes
defy description but what they do they
listen to the defendants whole story and
they say okay we we go to vote for life
without parole as opposed to death and
that's what's happening in America and
unfortunately a lot of these cases
involve men of color and both in your
book I was glad that in both these cases
they were both men of color who had been
falsely accused you're seeing more of
that so it's good to hear that jurors
are starting to be more skeptical
skeptical about the evidence and is
presented to them
gaile racism is so in here in the system
hey now because black defendants of
color are just treated differently yes
by the police and prosecutors enjoy us
it's the whole system treats them
different mm-hmm well you're shining a
light on that in this case that's my
that's my job flashlight played a very
crucial role and how about you a mug but
we always get coffee mugs here's that's
my compensation for being you watch you
your coffee mug baby made by my
son-in-law in Raleigh North Carolina you
don't pay them always the plug honey see
you next year again hello to Rene see
you next year
okay mrs. Gretchen the guardian's is on
sale today wherever you like to buy your
books